[MUSIC PLAYING]
ALEX SOUROV: Well, so
good afternoon, everyone.
So we are Facebook.
We are-- the two of us are from
the Android immersion markets
team in Facebook.
I'm Alex Sourov, the manager
of the emerging market team,
and here is--
ALEX PETRESCU: My
name is Alex Petrescu,
and I'm a software engineer
on the emerging markets team,
and I focus on the news feed.
ALEX SOUROV: And
today we're going
to talk about what we do
to make Android apps work
better on less powerful devices
and less powerful networks.
So first of all why we care
about emerging markets.
So we have almost
150 million users
using the app on a daily basis,
and these users are everywhere,
and we want to connect users
who are all over the world.
As a matter of fact, Android,
our Android users in particular
are located all over the world.
9 out of 10 of our
users are located
outside the United States.
And most of the new
users who come online
are also coming online in places
which are emerging markets.
We have a lot of people
who, for the first time,
actually getting
internet connections,
and of course, Facebook want
to connect to everybody,
and there is an ongoing
effort to do that.
Our job is to make
sure these users work
very well with Facebook for
Android app where they are.
And where they are typically,
with no offense for iOS users,
are Android devices, usually
cheap Android devices,
and network which are
not very powerful.
So we're going to talk
about devices first.
Does anybody here care to guess
how many different Android
devices are out
there in the market?
A number?
500, 1,000?
AUDIENCE: 10,000.
ALEX SOUROV: 10,000?
The right answer is 10,000.
You got that.
So there are about
10,000 devices,
and actually, the
number keeps increasing.
So that is about-- six months
ago it was about 10,000.
I'm not even sure
what is right now.
And of course, the challenge
is how do we actually test
and how do we reason
about 10,000 devices?
They're all very different.
Well, the way we
reason about them
is that it would come
up with this approach
called device year class.
So what's device year class?
Quite simply, it's-- no matter
when the device was produced,
it's the year at which
this device with those
characteristics would have
been the flagship device
on the market.
So here's how it works.
Moto E here is the recent
device, pretty popular device
from Motorola, of
course, came out in 2014,
but it has those
characteristics.
It has two CPU cores, 1.2
gigahertz clock speed,
and one gigabyte of RAM.
And let's compared
with Galaxy S2,
which is a very popular
device from 2011.
Has very similar characteristics
as far as these three
characteristics go.
And in 2011 that was
the flagship device.
So as a result, we're going to
say, hey, both of those devices
are year class 2011 devices.
And again, there are many
different characteristics
we could have looked at.
We looked at-- and we
looked at all them,
and we thought that these
three characteristics are
the ones that makes the
most difference in terms
of the performance of
the app and how users are
able to interface with the app.
So these are the
actual settings that
set up-- that we look at
for these three parameters.
And here's how we determine
whether a device is
in one year class or another.
On some devices you are not
going to get the exact match.
We go for two out of three.
If two out of free actually
match the year class,
we call these devices
from that year class.
And there's been a really
useful metric for us.
It's been useful for us
because all of a sudden
we can classify this whole
world of 10,000 devices
into smaller groups, and we can
reason about them more easily.
So once we actually
got this data,
we started seeing some
interesting trends,
and I'll let Alex
talk about that.
ALEX PETRESCU: So we developed
the concept of year class
a couple years ago.
It's mostly just
a simple library
that we've even open
sourced for other developers
to be able to introduce
this into their apps.
And once we looked
at the data, we
gathered a few months
of data, somewhere
around last year we saw that
about a third of all devices
will be considered 2010 devices.
These are mostly
Gingerbread devices.
You have one core, less
than a gigahertz clock,
and then usually also
other slow characteristics
like small cache size
and things like that.
Another third are 2011 devices,
and these are better devices.
They have two cores
but still not a lot
of clock speed,
not a lot of RAM,
but it seemed that was
the majority of users.
So we call 2010 and 2011
typical Android devices
because they were the
majority of the market.
And then the ones that we
have in our pockets, those
are the modern phones, the
high-end phones, the 2012.
You have more than
a couple cores,
more than a gig of
RAM, things like that.
Now, good news is that
this year 2010 has shrunk.
So there's a lot less
Gingerbread devices.
There's a lot less
single core devices.
However, the 2011 class is
now the most popular one
and continues to grow.
Most of the devices sold in
emerging markets, where they're
selling millions and
millions, they're
mostly on the 2011
side, so still only
two cores, which is a challenge.
It's a little bit better
for the United States.
Very few or fewer Gingerbread
users and single core devices,
but still, more than a third
of users are on 2011 devices.
So if you're building an
app, you still need to care,
and you care about any
sort of adoption outside
of major markets,
you should care
about these type of devices.
So as engineers,
instead of-- oh, shoot.
Sorry, I'm bad at this.
One second.
How do I go back?
OK, bam, got it.
All right, so as
engineers, instead
of worrying about 10,000
different devices,
now you really only need
to worry about eight.
And honestly, you only need
to worry about two or three.
You need to have a 2011 device.
You need to have a 2010
device like a pocket Neo,
and then you need to
have the device that's
in your pocket, which is
usually four cores or more
and a decent speed.
ALEX SOUROV: So
now that we talked
about the diversity of
devices, the next place
where there's a lot of
diversity in terms of usage
is diversity of
network conditions.
In some ways it's
even more complicated
than diversity of devices.
This is kind of the
basic graph here
that shows you a very
basic breakdown on network
conditions, and this is just by
Wi-Fi and cellular worldwide.
Most of the
connections-- of course,
this is from Facebook data and
sessions that Facebook have.
Most of the connections
out there on Wi-Fi.
I know there are quite a few
cellular, and then about 2%
worldwide actually
connect where there
is no connection whatsoever.
I mean, there might be
different reasons for that.
Users might have turned off the
mobile data or they in an area
where there is no mobile data.
Or they in the area
which is very congested,
and they can't get to the tower.
All of these are reasons for not
having any connections at all.
So that's simple enough,
but when you break it down
by countries, you'll
see that there's
a wide variety of
different conditions.
Even if you look just at
those three, Wi-Fi, cellular,
and no connection whatsoever,
these profiles vary a lot.
But it actually is even
more complicated than that.
I think probably everybody
notices that Wi-Fi, one Wi-Fi
is not like another Wi-Fi,
and one cellular connection
is not like another
cellular connection.
And so we took the page out
of device year class work,
and we thought, hey could we
actually do something similar
for network connections?
Could we actually
break it down into easy
to understand classifications
that we can then
use to reason about
them and to make
improvements for different
network connections?
And the idea we came up with
is network connection class.
And again, this is something
we open source and others can
use as well.
But in general, this is
fairly straightforward.
We are doing a passive
measurements of the bandwidth.
Like, as the app sends the
packets and receives them,
we keep track of how long it
takes and we measure bandwidth.
We throw out small packets
because the overhead
is actually starts [INAUDIBLE].
And we only look
for something which
is more than a certain size.
And then we get
these data points.
We get these data points
all over the place.
The mobile connections are
notoriously unreliable,
and at any given time you could
have a real good connection
and a really bed connection,
especially if you're
moving around, so we average.
So we looked at different
methods of averaging,
and we landed with a
geometric averaging.
So essentially, we break the
space of all the bandwidth
into two categories.
They're all about
4x from each other.
Moderate and poor connections
are the lowest ones
and then good and excellent.
And then we label them.
Again, to label them and
understand those boundaries we
look at the data again.
We wanted to find the boundaries
which are actually meaningful.
So as the user moves from one
connection class to another,
it results in a meaningful
change to performance
or meaningful change in
how the user can actually
interact with the app.
So this is the one we came
up with for the open source
library.
We just label them as poor,
moderate, good, and excellent
because in the future
we might actually
change what the boundaries are.
But we found that
these four average
is great groups for engineers
to think about and target
the app towards.
Alex?
ALEX PETRESCU: So
like Alex mentioned,
what we found is technology
does not imply speed.
And this is pretty apparent
to anyone that's actually
traveled and tried
to use hotel Wi-Fi
or try to go into an internet
cafe or something like that.
Just because you're
on Wi-Fi does not
mean that you're on a
good, fast connection.
So when you're thinking about
gating very expensive features
like auto play videos or HD
videos or things like that,
you can't just use that you're
on Wi-Fi or not on Wi-Fi
because that doesn't
really tell you anything.
Again, it doesn't-- if you're
on a LTE connection or 3G
connection, you might
have one bar or something.
You're still not getting
a good amount of speed.
So for example, in India
and in the United States,
the same download can
take four times longer
or be four times faster
in the United States
on average than in India for
the same connection type.
So this is what
Android gives you.
Android tells you
you're on Wi-Fi.
You're on mobile.
You're on edge.
You're on LTE.
But it doesn't really tell
you what the quality is
or how fast you're
getting packets
to and from your server.
So as developers we need
to build one amp, usually,
that has to work
on both six megs
a second and essentially
56K modem speeds.
So it's quite a
challenge for developers,
and connection
class is something
we've developed to help us
tackle these types of issues.
ALEX SOUROV: And now, this is a
talk about tales and somethings
that we find out which
might not be obvious,
and this is one of those things.
In general, if you were to
have a conditional in your app
and say, hey, if I
think about Japan,
do I think about bad
connections or do
I think about good connections?
I think just
everybody would agree
that you are thinking about
good connections, really
good connections for
most users in Japan.
But when we put this data and
started looking at this data,
we found this.
So at the end of every month
about 10% percent of users
in Japan switch from
excellent connections
to not so great connections,
poor and moderate connections.
So we started wondering
why, and the title kind of
gives it away as to
why this happens,
the title of the slide.
But the thing that's happening
is that basically, users
are either on prepaid
plans or they're basically
throttled by their carrier
when they use too much data.
And so again, if
you are just looking
at the country or the type
of the connection, Wi-Fi
or cellular, you're
probably missing out
on some group of the population
which actually doesn't quite
fit the profile.
ALEX PETRESCU: So you
guys have seen this slide
a few slides ago.
And we talked about the
different breakdowns
and what I'd like to point out
is now the intermittency issue,
is that there's a certain time
no matter what country you're
in, no matter what
network you're on,
where you turn on your
app, and for some reason
you don't have a
network right now.
This is obviously a
much bigger problems
in places like India
or Nigeria, where
something like 20%
of all app startups
do not have any network at all.
But still, even in
the United States
we've all been on the subway,
on the bus, or something
like that, where there's
no connection right now.
And even though you have
a network connection,
or Android will tell you you
have a network connection,
what we found is
packets will go out,
and then they'll
just essentially just
go into a black hole somewhere
and then never come back.
Nothing comes back.
So what we found is, like, 20%
of all network requests fail.
And this is while the
app is in the foreground,
so we know that the user's
trying to use the app.
While the app is
in the background,
it could be 50%,
60% if you're trying
to make a network request
while it' in the background.
ALEX SOUROV: So in
addition to that,
we believe that the
improvements, especially
on the networking side, are
going to take some time.
So 2G is being phased out in
the U.S. Which is great news.
But it's going to be
around in the emerging
marketplaces for a while,
at least for a few years.
But that's not even
the whole problem.
The bigger problem
is the congestion
because if you go to
the emerging marketplace
and you try the 3G
over there, what will
you often find that 3G
is not like our 3G here.
And the reason is,
it's really congested
and it's not reliable.
And congestion comes from a lot
of people using the networks.
And more and more people
are getting online.
More and more people are using
internet for the first time,
and that's fantastic news.
Unfortunately,
the infrastructure
is not catching up with that.
So we expect that the congestion
issues are going to continue
and that it's not going to get
any more reliable anytime soon.
And here's our tale off the
connectivity in the Facebook
Hyderabad office.
So as an emerging
market teams, we
make trip to emerging market
countries pretty regularly.
And this year we
really focused on India
because we wanted to
understand and solve
a lot problems in that market.
So we went there twice so far.
We went there in January
and we went there in July.
And when we went there in
January, we were disappointed.
The connection was too good.
You got 3G speeds.
The office happens to be in
a high tech part of the town.
And they got a
little cell towers
over there, a lot of
high tech companies.
So generally, connection
was excellent.
It was like oh, that's too bad.
We can't really get a
representative sample
right there.
So we had to fan
out of the office
and go to more remote areas and
stay in the cafes and coffee
shops, and just basically
see what the connectivity is.
Try to analyze the pattern,
try to analyze what apps works
and what don't.
So when they came in
July, things reversed.
All of a sudden, in the
office, the conditions
were not that great.
Or actually for us,
they were great.
We got this juicy intermittency,
and bad latencies,
and everything.
And so we asked Caretel,
which is on the biggest cell
providers over there what's
going on, and they said,
well, is there any
more construction
in the area that happened
between January and July?
And sure enough, there are
two new office buildings
right next door.
They said, well let's probably
between 2,000 and 6,000 people
there.
So that's what happens.
All of a sudden your
network is congested.
And we're like, well,
what are you guys going
to do about this?
They said, well, we'll put a
new cell tower in the area,
but it takes about
six to nine months
to put a new cell
tower in the area.
And so in the meantime, that's
what you're going to get.
And so that was actually
pretty eye opening.
We tend to think about
progress as linear.
Things are just improving.
And in reality, goes
kind of like that, right?
Sometimes things have to get
worse before they get better.
And Hyderabad is particularly
interesting in that,
because if you look at
this chart over there
about population
growth in Hyderabad,
the city's been
growing really fast.
So not only are a lot
of people coming online
for the first time,
adding to this congestion,
people are moving around.
And when that happens, more and
more people come to one place,
they overwhelm the
infrastructure.
ALEX PETRESCU: A
point about that one.
So the last data point is 2011.
They've added another 3 million
people in the last four years.
So this year or last year,
they had 9 million people.
So they added as many
people in the last three
years or four years as
they added the previous 10
years before.
ALEX SOUROV: Actually, another
interesting anecdote about this
is if you go to a
rural area in India,
as long as you stay
to a major highway,
when you leave a large city,
your connection improves.
Because along the
major highways,
your connectivity is
actually pretty descent.
And congestion start
getting less and less.
So like just outside
of the cities,
as long as you stick
to the major highway,
you actually have really
good connectivity.
ALEX PETRESCU: So this is
everyday life for most people
in emerging markets.
However, the more
we looked at this,
the more we realized this is not
really just an emerging markets
problem.
This is really a subway problem.
This is a crowded
stadium problem.
conference problem.
This is a road trip problem.
This is an airplane problem.
Or if you're in New York
City or somewhere around,
its your bad reception
in your house.
It's essentially
issues boiled down
to when you're
building mobile apps,
the network is your enemy.
It doesn't really matter
how good your phone is
if you're on a bad network or
you happen to be in a situation
where you're on a bad
network right now,
your experience, your
user's experience
is going to be pretty terrible.
ALEX SOUROV: So when
we think about how
we address this
issue, especially
for the network issue,
we kind of break it down
in two different classes.
One is a strategies
for modern phones.
Phone is not a limitation.
It's not a constraint.
But network is.
How do we deal with that?
And the other one
is the situation
where your phone is
actually a limitation.
So we're going to start
talking about strategies
for modern phone first.
So phones that
actually have storage,
phone have pretty good CPU,
and phones that generally look
like the desktop computers
of five years ago,
or even better than that.
ALEX PETRESCU: So the
easiest thing you can do
is cache the data
that you download.
So this is very
important, especially
for images and a lot
of things that take
a lot of bytes over the wire.
But it's also important
for just simple responses,
like from your servers for
metadata and things like that.
And the reason this is, because
the user might wake up the app.
And they might have a
network connection right now.
Or you might have downloaded
data yesterday for a view
that they're clicking today.
So try to cache as
much data as possible.
You have the hardware
on the device.
You have the storage.
Your users will generally
thank you for it.
Also, since you have CPUs,
and you have cores and threads
that are available,
to try to preprocess
your media before uploading.
If you're going to
use a photo on a site
and it's going to be
a thousand pixels,
don't upload a five megapixel
or 10 megapixel image
from the device.
It doesn't make any sense to
then throw 99% of the bytes
away once they
get to the server.
Preprocess it first on the
client, and then upload it.
Do it in the
background obviously.
Tell the user that
you're doing stuff
so he knows why
his phone is hot.
But do it on the device.
And then make sure, essentially,
anytime you're posting,
you're serializing, you queue
these up in the background.
So never require
network to post data.
So if I'm uploading
a bunch of photos,
allow me to essentially
queue those up right now,
because that's when I
want to do it, right now.
And then you do it
in the background
whenever you have a connection.
Don't make me essentially
wait, look for a spinner.
And then use the threads.
Especially, for example,
things like view inflation,
is very expensive.
It takes a while,
especially on older phones.
If you need data for that
view, start the network
fetch literally as early as
possible, maybe sometimes
even on the screen beforehand.
So by the time that
the view is loaded,
they don't have to wait
those extra 500 milliseconds,
a second to do that.
So next, use the
network cleverly.
So we talk about caching.
If you have a good cache,
one thing you could do
is prefetch data.
So prefetching comes in
different shapes and sizes.
It could mean prefetch for the
next 30 seconds of interactions
or 3 minutes of
interactions, or prefetch
for later on today,
if it's a notification
or something like that.
And then maximize the
usage of the network
when it's available.
If you have a
connection right now,
you need to get a bunch
of data for a list view
or something like that,
try to get it all at once.
There's many different
reasons for this.
Mostly mobile
networks are bursty.
So once you get a
connection, it's great.
You have data.
Stuff are going to come over
the network very quickly.
And also, once it's done,
the radio can go to sleep.
So that will use
less battery usage.
And your users
will be happy too.
But when you're
prefetching, you're
doing all the extra
stuff, you need
to make sure you
prioritize cancel requests
if the user switches
and does something else.
If you predicted that they're
going to scroll in the list
and they decide to
click on something,
cancel all their request
that you currently
are doing for the list.
Trunk responses, especially this
is-- I talk a lot about lists
because I work on News Feed.
Lists are my life.
So you know, if you need
the data for 10 stories
and you're on a fast
connection, that's great.
Wait till you get those 10
stories because it's only going
to take you a few milliseconds.
However, if you're
on a slow connection,
you only need two stories,
or maybe five rows of data
in order to show to the user.
So just tell the server,
give me the first five.
Let me process it.
And then give me the
rest in the background.
So you can return those first
few responses to the UI very,
very quickly.
These type of things
are great optimizations
for just user experience.
Keep your requests small,
especially when you're sending.
Packet size matters.
Usually I think it's like, 1
and 1/2 kilobytes or something
like that.
Try to fit your
request inside of that.
So that has the highest
likelihood of actually getting
to your server quickly.
And then this is a
hyper-optimization,
but something that's
actually quite important.
DNS is quite unreliable
for some reason.
So even though the user
has an active connection,
and if you connect
via IP, it works fine.
Often, DNS servers will fail.
And it's really, really lame.
I think, one of
the optimizations,
I think WhatsApp or
something has done,
but it's a great
way to essentially
just have a fallback.
If you can't do
a DNS resolution,
try to fallback
to something else.
It might work.
And it will be
great for your user.
ALEX SOUROV: And
prefetching doesn't
come without its challenges.
I think anybody who
actually tried that knows.
The challenge is fairly obvious.
It's server CPU, data costs,
battery usage, storage.
And it can get in the way of
the interactions with the user.
Even if you're
trying to prefetch
when the user is
not doing anything,
they can start at any moment.
And sometimes cancelling
those fetches is not cheap.
So prefetching is
inherently probabilistic,
because you are basically
guessing that the user is
going to use the data.
And that's where most
of the challenges
are going to come from,
because if you guess wrong,
you just incur all this
cost without any benefits.
So to deal with that,
we'll talk a little bit
about what smart
prefetching looks like.
ALEX PETRESCU: So
smart prefetching,
because there's
lots of challenges.
Use the cache data creatively.
In our app, for example, when
you wake up the app initially,
we'll show you stories
you've already downloaded.
We're starting to
essentially show you
story that we have
in your cache,
but you've never seen before.
So there's no reason to show you
something that we already have
and wait for the network.
And then this is great,
because in offline mode,
you can still open up our app.
You can scroll through
your news feed.
You can like and comment.
There won't be
any fresh stories.
Obviously you still
need a network for that.
But there will be stories
relatively recently.
And then if you can,
normalize the data.
You might have different
endpoints that return
different pieces of the story.
You might have a list view
that returns part of the data,
and then a detail view
that has more data.
So essentially, take the
data from the list view
and put it on top
of your detail view
while you're loading
the rest of the data.
The users essentially doesn't
have to wait for this view
to load.
He sees something.
There's not just a
big spinner on screen.
And Google has given
us JobScheduler,
and the GcmNetworkManager for
pre-Lollipop devices, which
makes all this much, much
easier, and much more
efficient.
We can optimize
for battery usage,
make sure these
type of prefetches,
especially in the
background, will
happen at the same
time with other stuff.
They will happen on the
types of networks we want.
The network will be available.
Like I mentioned
before, you can start
the app in the background, but
there's a very high likelihood
that your request will fail
because they have mobile off,
or for various reasons.
And then you can do
things like not prefetch
on certain connection types.
So we have Connection class.
And what we found is that
on really fast networks,
prefetching is useless.
Don't do it.
It's not worth the cost.
Because your paying-- the
amount of time users are waiting
is so small that it's not
worth you guessing and missing,
and then using resources
in the background
and trying to process
stuff while the user us
doing something.
So just don't do it.
Doesn't matter which
type of device it is.
If you are on a fast
connection, there's
no point in prefetching.
You're not going to
get a lot of benefit.
ALEX SOUROV: Unless
it's intermittent.
You have to deal
with that, fine.
ALEX PETRESCU: Sure.
There's lots of challenges.
And then when of the
hardest problems in computer
science is cache invalidation.
So making sure when--
keeping your cache fresh.
This might mean periodically
during delta syncs
and be like hey, has
anything changed?
And the server can just
say like, yes or no,
as opposed to just
re-downloading everything
all the time.
ALEX SOUROV: And the story
we're going to tell you here
is the story of
comment prefetching
and how we sort of
thought about this.
If you use the Facebook app,
you know that you generally
get the stories.
And then to get to the comments,
you click on the button.
You get the comment
counts, but you
need to click on the
button to go to them.
And for a variety of
reasons, fetching comments
is a pretty expensive operation
and may take some time.
So it seemed like an ideal
candidate for prefetching,
and it does help a
lot with performance.
But there is a problem.
Even users who use the app
a lot don't necessary click
on every single common
count for every single story
to see their comments.
As a matter of fact, the
majority of the stories,
users don't click
on the comments.
They don't look at them.
And so the problem is, how
do you make it efficient?
That's a great scenario for a
more probabilistic approach.
So we're going to try to guess
whether you're actually going
to read this comment or not.
In some cases it's fairly easy,
because occasionally we show
you a story you've seen before.
But it's got more
comments and more likes.
In which case, we're already
showing you this story
because it's got comments.
So it's a good one to prefetch.
In other case it's a
little bit trickier.
There are different
parameters that we
take into consideration.
And we actually have a
system on the server that
does machine learning
and tries to figure out
how likely are you to actually
look at the comment or not.
And then the server sends this
probability back to the client,
and the client can look
at that and say, well,
do I want to prefetch or
not, depending on what kind
of device you are running
and what kind of conditions
you are under.
So that's an example of how
probabilistic prefetch works
fairly well.
That also means that
sometimes when you are offline
or in a bad connection,
occasionally you
click on the comments,
it will take some time.
But we have generally
pretty good about this.
And so most the time,
when you actually
want to look at the comment,
it's going to be there for you.
So now strategies
for low end phone.
Low ends phones is a completely
different situation here,
because in the low end phones.
You actually have
limitations of the device.
And you have to worry
about those constraints.
And the biggest constraints
you have to deal with is space.
ALEX PETRESCU: So
it's a challenge.
But if you're targeting
low end phones,
one of the biggest
hardship users
have is that very
low disk space.
So often upgrading your app
or downloading a new app
is very challenge for a user.
You have to delete one
of the other four apps
that they can have on the
phone at the same time.
So developing an app that has
a lightweight app footprint
is paramount for
these type of phones.
Next, caching is a premium.
Again, very low disk
storage on the device.
So if you're taking
up another 100 megs
to store images that
they may or may not see,
that's not going to be a
good trade off for the user.
And honestly, for
most of these users,
the mobile website
is their fallback.
And it's like, oh, I
can't install this app.
I really want to use this
feature, this service,
this website I've heard about.
I don't have space to
download or I don't
have a good enough connection.
So make sure you have
a good mobile website.
And by good, I mean
not a desktop web site
that just happens to fit
inside of the window.
You really need to have
one that is specifically
focused for these type of users
and these type of devices.
They're the ones most
likely to use this website.
So to take a term
from web development,
you should essentially build
progressively, enhance site.
Essentially make
sure your site has
the features necessary without
JavaScript, without CSS.
Because these users might have
turned that off because it's
slow for them.
And then a new thing that
has come out last year
is that you can
essentially have many
of the benefits of
native applications using
push notifications
on mobile websites.
So we're going to talk about the
push notifications a little bit
later.
So you won't have to deal
with these type of phones
or networks.
These are a little bit older
than what we're targeting.
But it's still best to send
as little data as possible
over the wire.
We're talking about,
no metadata at all.
If you're not rendering
on this screen
at this exact point in time,
do not send it over the wire.
Focus on essentially formats.
JSON is a great
format for developers.
It's kind of verbose
when it comes to devices.
So other essentially
binary protocol
such as protobufs, or
we use flat buffers--
that allow you essentially
to send bytes over the wire
and data over the wire without
having the paid deserialization
costs.
And so that goes back
to pre-processing data
on the server.
Don't send metadata.
If you're concatenating
a bunch of strings,
don't do it on the client.
Do it on the server.
Minimize background
work and I/O,
because you only have one core.
So it's going to
interfere with things
that are happening on the UI.
It's going to be pretty crappy.
And then minimize the number
of simultaneous requests.
Often on 2G networks
and low end networks,
you don't have the
available upstream bandwidth
to send multiple requests
at the same time.
So essentially throttle yourself
to one request at a time.
ALEX SOUROV: Some
things you just
can't do on low
end devices are--
at least we haven't figured
out a way to do that.
For example, how would you
deal with intermittency
if you don't have
the cache space
and you can't really
prefetch ahead of time?
Pretty hard.
But you can do fairly
well in situations
where the network
which is just slow.
So the tale here is the mobile
web and push applications.
The one thing I want to
mention about mobile app
is there is a misconception
that on Android, mobile web is
going down in terms of numbers.
And the native
applications are going up.
And actually, what's true
is both are going up.
Because a lot of
users are switching
from feature phones--
I mean, a lot of them
are switching to devices which
is just not powerful enough
to run some of the functionality
we have in the main app.
And they opt for using
the mobile web instead.
And we think for some devices,
it's a perfectly great solution
to do that.
So the usage is growing
for both of those.
And I think for most other
apps, that's true as well.
And push applications is
just really exciting topic
because up until
this year, what, push
notifications in the browser?
Where did they come from?
And so this year, we
actually originally partnered
with UC Mini and
UC Browser, which
is a very popular browser
in China and India
to provide push notifications.
And we did that with UC Mini,
and then we did it with Opera.
And in both cases, we
saw a tremendous response
from the users.
Very active push notifications
is a great functionality.
And so they visited
the app more often.
And then we worked with Google.
Google was very interested in
building as a platform feature.
And they did that.
In Chrome right
now, you actually
can have different apps do
the same thing that we did
and provide push
notifications for them.
So they have a platform, and
apps can actually do that now.
And they're seeing similar
response for all of them.
I mean, it's just
been great for users
who can't have a native app
installed on their device,
or prefer to use a
mobile web instead.
Firefox is the last
major mobile browser.
And they announced
recently that their support
for push notifications is also
coming sometime this year.
So everybody's moving
in that direction.
It's pretty great.
ALEX PETRESCU: Want
to stop for questions?
ALEX SOUROV: Yeah.
I mean, I think we had
a lot of materials.
We have about 15 minutes more
of more material to cover.
But we wanted to stop
and see if people
have any questions
before we go on,
about the material
we just presented.
If people have
general questions,
they can also come
out afterwards.
Anybody?
Yep, there's a question there.
AUDIENCE: So shining a light
on some very big problems
to solve.
So for companies that don't have
the resources engineering wise
to do all that, do you have any
suggestions or what to pick off
and start with instead
of going like oh,
our app is terrible
compared to Facebook's?
Any typical first
steps involved?
ALEX SOUROV: Right.
So the question the
question is, a lot of stuff
here is pretty high end like
maybe utilizing the server
power and require a lot
of development work.
For companies who
are just starting
to think about the
emerging markets, what
are the first few things they
could do to make things better?
Alex, you want to take that?
ALEX PETRESCU: Sure.
I think a lot of the things
that we're talking about,
things like caching data
and optimizing for your app
not being online at
this very second,
are kind of just
user experience.
And those are
just- you just have
to have those assumptions when
you're building your product.
It's really hard to
go back afterwards
and being like, oh,
I'm going to redesign
it to work in these things.
It's quite challenging.
I know, we're doing it.
But when you're building,
for a small company,
you can move much faster.
And you can do a lot.
But things like caching
data, it's not hard.
Like images and
things like that,
that's no brainer type stuff.
Prefetching in lists
and things like that
are also not-- understanding
your users and their flow,
understanding who your uses are.
So implementing Connection
class in your class, just purely
for your analytics
first, that's actually
most important what we found.
Just implement it as
part of your analytics.
Try to understand
what's going on.
And then optimize for
scenarios that you see.
Like you might see
a login flow is
broken and has a huge drop off
on your class 2010 devices.
So you can grab a year
class 2010 device,
and then optimize for
that, as opposed to trying
to do everything up front,
which is challenging.
So data first.
Analytics first.
And then find the big
problems in your app.
ALEX SOUROV: And there is
many open source things
like year, class, and
network connection classes
too, because a lot of
engineers in other companies
were asking hey, what can we do?
And we thought that would
be useful for them as well.
But there are some basic
[INAUDIBLE] as Alex said.
You know, just catching.
ALEX PETRESCU: And we're going
to talk about a few things
like right now, some
tools and some ideas
that we've essentially built
into our apps to essentially
solve this issue.
Because it is a very
difficult problem.
ALEX SOUROV: Any more
questions before we move on?
No.
All right.
So moving on to testing.
Most of us are here, we have
the connections that we have.
And they're pretty good.
How do we test for bad networks?
How do we test for
how the apps work,
our apps work on bad networks?
ALEX PETRESCU: So
one of the things
we built last year is called
Augmented Traffic Control.
And it's a tool
we've open sourced.
It's a server you run on one of
the computers in your office.
And then it provides
essentially-- you connect
to it via Wi-Fi on your phone.
So essentially all the
traffic from your app
or other apps on
your phone could
go through Augmented
Traffic Control.
And then there's
presets on there,
so you can, for example,
see what my app feel
like on 2G in rural India.
Or when there's a black hole,
and I'm sending packets out,
and everything is telling
me I have a connection,
but nothing is coming back,
how does my app behave
in these type of scenarios?
So it's all open sourced.
And you guys can look it up.
But essentially it's
just a server somewhere
with some simple software
that will both handle latency,
bandwidth, and also
things like intermittency.
So some requests will
be faster than others.
They'll be bursty, things
like that, some more complex
modeling.
Next, Genymotion is out here.
And they're a great tool
and a great emulator.
So they've built the ability
to throttle your network.
And they have presets
like 3G, and 4G, and Edge.
So you can easily
see what it's like.
I actually got stuck on one
of these modes the other day.
And I was like, why
is my app so slow?
Everything is loading.
And I was like, oh,
I'm actually on Edge.
I was like, this is what people
are feeling every single day.
It is terrible.
I'm sorry.
And then there's also
the Android emulator.
And it provides,
essentially, parameters
you can pass in to tell
it, I want to be on Edge.
I want to be on GPS.
I want to be on Wi-Fi, and then
what the actual delay and speed
is for those networks.
ALEX SOUROV: So a lot
of this technologies,
they're sort of Wi-Fi throttling
technologies or some variations
of that.
And Wi-Fi throttling is used
by other companies as well.
ATC is not the only
solution for that.
The tricky thing
about Wi-Fi throttling
is that you can't
really dogfood.
You can test, but you
can't really dogfood.
You can't just
take that on a bus
and try doing things, right, or
things you do in a daily life.
And dogfooding is
very important.
When we develop
our apps, we rely
on dogfooding a lot
to sort of understand
how the features feel
and how they work.
And that's a challenge.
Because with Wi-Fi
throttling and ATC,
we don't actually get that.
So we have a couple ideas
and how to solve that.
And one of them is
VPN throttling, just
building a VPN app which can
just throttle you as well.
And it could throttle
you all the time
and all of the apps on
your phone all the time.
And it can work with
a current network
and then just throttle it.
So that's one
dogfooding solution.
But another one, and
just to the question
about how do you
do simple things,
is don't underestimate the power
of sleep statement in your app.
If you just have it
for the dogfooders
or for the engineers where you
just slow down your network
calls, all of them,
that's actually
a great way to model latency.
Just have it parameterizable
so you can change this.
But that's one way to do that.
And another way, simple way
to do things, for example,
to demonstrate what
intermittency might look
is just fail the network calls.
You're not going to get
the entire richness of how
the networks work and how
many ways they can fail,
but it'll give you
a basic idea of what
happens when your network
calls starts failing randomly,
and how the app can handle this.
And the story I
want to tell here
is a story of 2G Tuesdays,
which is something
we started doing internally.
And we basically used these
techniques, just a simple sleep
statement to get
the latency and just
randomly return network
failures even if the network is
perfectly fine.
And then we ping
employees every Tuesday
if you're on Android device.
And we ask you if you want
to come in and participate
in the 2G Tuesdays.
And when you do, you
get those latencies.
and you get those
intermittencies.
Again, not the entire
richness, but you
get enough to actually generate
a lot of interesting bugs.
So obviously users
are encouraged
to use and dogfood the
app as long as they can,
as long as they want to.
And that's been a great
source of bug reports,
things which we otherwise would
not have found until they app
went into the production.
And it's also a great
way to build empathy.
Like Alex was talking
about, nothing
like just seeing a view
like that for five,
10 seconds to sort of
understand what the problem is
and really, really feel the
empathy with the people who
have to go for this every day.
ALEX PETRESCU: So next,
my favorite thing,
because it's actually the
solution to all these problems,
is configuration.
So we build our
apps and we usually
optimize for a certain
scenario, usually our scenario.
I open the app, and I
click these buttons.
And it works.
And I close it, and
I'm like, it's done.
It works.
I guarantee it.
Then we ship it and someone
clicks, and then it breaks.
And you're like, why did
you click it that way?
So yes, we're terrible at this.
However, constants are bad.
That's what we found
is that-- I like
the quote-- "the only thing
that is constant is change."
So we essentially have
allowed most, if not
all of our features
of our app, to have
parameters for everything
that could be configured.
So things that would normally
be a static final const
in your class is
now a parameter.
It's still a const, but it could
be overridden on the server.
And so what we do
is then it allows
us to optimize all sorts
of different interactions
and feelings inside of our
app for your current device.
Like we showed less
images on screen
depending on your
not only device size,
but your year class.
There's some devices that
have big screens and very
little RAM.
It is really annoying.
If these devices don't
have a lot of disk space,
we reduced the cache.
If an animation we
think is really cool
does not perform
well, we can just
turn it off on certain devices.
It's like oh, you're class 2010.
There's no point in making
the user sit and watch
a stuttering animation.
We just turn it off
and show the screen.
And then we can optimize for
the current network, which
is some of the
most powerful stuff
that we've been able to do.
So examples being like having
fewer or more concurrent
connections when
you're on Wi-Fi,
make all the requests
at the same time.
It doesn't matter.
If you're on 2G, make
one request at a time.
If you're on 2G, download
an image resolution
that will load in an
appropriate amount of time.
Even though it should
be 500 by 400 pixels,
if that's going to take
you 30 seconds to download,
no one's going to wait there
30 seconds for this image
to download.
Download a lower res
version to at least show
the user in five, 10 seconds.
And then I mentioned
chunking before.
You can change the chunk sizes.
And then when to prefetch,
don't prefetch on fast networks.
Prefetch more on slow
networks, et cetera.
So experimentation is good.
Once you have all these
parameters, step number two.
It's harder for
smaller companies.
But you can start out small.
Essentially start
running A/B tests
with different parameters.
Don't assume you
know as a developer,
I know this is how
or user should use.
You're not Steve Jobs.
You need to make sure your
app works for the scenarios
that your users
are actually using.
So when you're
looking at this data,
don't settle for the average.
Make sure you use the analytics
available to you, year, class,
connection class, country,
to really make sure
that you're not hurting
a certain segment
of the population.
It might be, on average, good.
But it might hurt
a small segment
of the population really bad.
We found, for example,
out of memory errors
for one feature was
really bad on one thing,
even though for overall
it increased engagement.
And things like that
for other people.
And then once you've done
that, you're not done.
You're never done,
especially if you
have an app that has
a long life cycle
and is living over
several years.
The people who are using your
app will change over time.
There will be early
adopters first,
and then there will be
like grandmas later.
They use the app different ways.
They have different patterns.
You have to make sure
that what was true
a year ago is still true now.
ALEX SOUROV: And I'll tell
here is a tale of MobileConfig,
which is basically
our configuration
system for doing these things.
The key part of the system
is where actually we
want to push a lot of those
parameters from, the server.
So we can quickly adjust them
or use the power of the server
to do analysis and decide,
hey, for this type of users,
this is the best value.
And so that's
precisely what we do.
So different users can
get different parameters
and different values.
So the behavior of
that app, especially
on the infrastructure side,
adjusts to what we think
is best for them based
on experimentation.
That system allows
us to experiment
on things in any time.
So even if we are pretty
sure that this is the best
configuration
parameter, it might not
be the best configuration
parameter six months later.
So we can repeat
this and do it again.
In the meantime, start with
just a [INAUDIBLE] constants.
From the client perspective,
it's just something
comes from the sky.
And they just use that.
How it's actually
send is not relevant.
And one tricky thing about
this, in mobile world,
especially on Android, people
don't upgrade very quickly.
You still have a lot of
old versions out there.
And you have to
sort of owner that.
So if you ever build
a system like that,
you have to worry about
versioning and making sure
that you can deal with that.
There are many different
ways to deal with that.
But that's one of the
problems you have to solve.
And then sort of going
beyond A/B testing,
I want to talk about
Facebook Bandit.
It certainly on the high
end of what you can do,
but it's pretty exciting for us.
So we wanted to mention that.
It's built by Facebook
research, so a lot of the stuff
is pretty complex.
So we just want to talk about
sort of the basic things
involved in the system.
It's an advanced
experimentation framework.
It's common in the industry.
It's called multi-armed bandit.
That happens to be
the Facebook version
of that, Facebook Bandit.
What it allows you to
do is to experiment
with a large number
of configurations.
And it very quickly
decides how to narrow down
to just the configurations which
are likely to produce the best
results.
It also very quickly decides
how to throw out configurations
which are producing results
which are worse than the status
quo, which is important, because
you don't want have experiments
out there which actually
degrade user experience.
So that system helps us
to get there quickly.
And it allows us to optimize
for competing variables.
Quite often for
those configurations,
you are not just thinking
about one variable.
A great example
here is data usage.
You do data usage so
your performance improves
and users spend more
time working with the app
than they do looking
at the spinner.
But data usage itself is of
course one of the parameters,
and you don't want to
drive that value too high.
And the story here
is the story of how
we did the prefetching
while scrolling.
So as we scroll
through the News Feed,
we prefetch stories
ahead of time
because we don't want you to
hit that moment where you're
sort of visibly
looking at the spinner
while we're trying to get
the next set of stories.
And originally when
we did this, we just
said, well, we'll just A/B
test, look at a few values.
And we find out that
generally, worldwide,
10 is a fantastic number.
It could be the best number.
And we just prefetch
10 stories ahead.
When you are 10 stories
from the moment where
we don't have anymore stories,
we will go ahead and prefetch.
And then when the bandit
came onto the scene,
we decided that we're going
to run this for the bandit.
So we can figure out
the best configurations
for different networks
in particular,
because we had this hunch that
from the different networks,
we might get
something different.
Bandit actually went for 27
different configurations.
A configuration is
something like that,
like all metrics over
here, different number
of stories that
you prefetch ahead
for on different connections.
And first, they're
sort of random
and look at what
the usage would look
like from different
configurations.
But the real
interesting thing here
is optimization for
multiple parameters.
Because yeah, you
can reduce data usage
by doing fewer than 10, but you
want to do that in such a way
that users don't end up
looking at that spinner,
because the entire work
is there to make sure
that you can actually
get to the stories
before user gets to them.
And so their
engagement continues
to be high because
they're engaging
with the app instead of waiting
for the stories to load.
And so when you actually map
these 27 different cases,
you see this pattern which,
pareto frontier is just
a fancy word of saying for all
the other configurations here,
there is a better
configuration where
you can improve on one axis
without sacrificing anything
on the other.
And so the tool helps
us to figure this out.
And actually it turns out that
there are those four different
values out of these
27 that are like that,
which cannot be improved any
further on one of the other
axes.
Two of them are extreme.
You can obviously run
with no data usage.
But then you're not going
to get much out of this.
Or you could just say,
you're going to get a lot.
But data usage is
we still a concern
and you have to worry about.
And then you are just
down to two values.
And then you can A/B
test on these two values
and figure out what
the best value is.
And I'll let Alex finish
on that because that
was one of his projects.
ALEX PETRESCU: Yes.
So we start off with 10.
That seemed like a good number.
We tested out 27
different configurations.
And what we found is that 10 was
actually a pretty good number.
We did a pretty decent job
for certain types of users.
And it didn't hurt anyone else.
But, we could actually
optimize, when
you're on good and
excellent networks,
to prefetch less aggressively.
So this actually reduced
data usage for these people
dramatically, because now they
didn't essentially download
things they didn't need.
And also decreased server CPU.
We saw like, what is it,
57% of users were on Wi-Fi.
So 57% of users used to, or
some percentage of that 57%
used to prefetch relatively
aggressively when
they didn't need to.
So we were able to
drastically reduce
server CPU, which costs
money, without actually
hurting engagement.
No one saw anymore spinners.
Probably no one noticed.
So then we just now
have one set of values.
But we do it instead
of 10, we now
do it based on connection class.
So you can see we actually
have a JSON configuration
object that looks exactly that.
We say when you're on
excellent, use three.
When you're on good, use five.
And these will change, right?
You might be on an
excellent connection now.
And you turn off Wi-Fi, and
you go walk out the door.
And now you need to
do another fetch.
Now you get the value 10.
So these values can change
over the lifetime of the app.
And that's it.
That was a lot.
ALEX SOUROV: That's
our presentation.
So thanks very much for coming.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]